en plein confinement on transpire dans
cette salle de sport à guyancourt
la structure est l'une des seules dans
les yvelines à rester ouverts pendant
l'ensemble de la période
la raison elle peut accueillir des
sportifs de haut niveau et surtout des
adhérents présentant une ordonnance
médicale
c'est sur prescription médicale donc
c'est une prescription par un certificat
qui fait en fait office comme une
ordonnance la nécessité de faire du
sport alors comme je vous dis pour
diverses pathologies
ça peut être physique comme un mal de
dos un problème hypertension problème de
lombers etc ou un problème même mental
ça peut être problème dépression stress
au travail on entend de plus en plus à
cause du confinement le télétravail créé
beaucoup de soucis et ça peut être une
pathologie qui donne accès à notre club
au total plus de 100 personnes viennent
s'entraîner dans cette salle de sport
chaque semaine certains viennent presque
quotidiennement l'objectif c'est bien
sûr c'est pouvoir être beaucoup plus
sereine
psychologiquement ça fait du bien ça
détend après j'ai aussi moins un
objectif sportif donc j'ai besoin de
maintenir la pratique du sport
si je maintiens pas cette pratique de ce
sport là dans mon objectif sportif
forcément il est beaucoup plus compliqué
à atteindre je vais devoir faire comme
tout le monde
rester chez moi avec mes poings mais à
terre mais bart et mes bouteilles d'eau
malgré six adhérents sur ordonnance la
structure a vu sa fréquentation baisser
de 50%
personnellement mais pour moi c'est une
bonne chose parce que le sport c'est
bien aussi bien mentalement que
physiquement c'est hyper important
et pour moi avoir une activité sportive
physique quotidienne ça nous permet aux
personnes en tenue militaire d'être bien
mieux dans sa tête
les salles de musculation attendent
maintenant les annonces du déconfinement